okay let's return to our breaking news
story we are hearing from the news
agency Reuters that 16 people including
Ukraine's interior Minister as well as
other senior Ministry officials have
been killed today Wednesday when a
helicopter crashed outside Kiev in the
town of Bravery now let's go straight to
our correspondent Natasha Butler who I
believe is now near the crash site what
more can you tell us
yeah we're pretty much at the crash site
just behind me is a kindergarten that is
where the helicopter came down just
after eight o'clock local time I don't
know if you can see at all but we can
see emergency workers and police at the
scene a part of the building is
completely burnt out and all around me
are residents in this area it is a
residential area they've come to see
what is happening it's very quiet it's
very still people are very shocked
indeed there's still a real smell of
smoke in the air now what we're learning
is uh that 16 people this is according
to the bavari police 16 people have been
killed including two children we also
have heard that there were nine people
on that helicopter including senior
political government figures here in
Kiev and the interior Minister the
interior Minister that has been killed
in this crash now we don't know any more
about the circumstances of the crash Why
down at this point of course this is
very much much something that's just
happened a few hours ago but we are in
this small town of bavari it's just on
the edge of key even as you can imagine
a real shock for many people indeed and
particularly in political circles news
that the interior Minister and I believe
his Deputy also killed in this crash
I suppose at this point one of the first
questions is the the helicopter itself
who the helicopter belonged to why it
crashed what more do we know do we know
anything about it
uh no not at all what we understand it
was carrying nine people including these
senior political figures including we
understand the interior Minister now
where it was going where it come from we
don't have any details at all I mean I'm
sure some of those will emerge as the
day goes on and why it crashed we don't
know there were some reports from some
residents saying that they saw the
helicopter in the air that perhaps a
propeller was on fiber none of that has
been verified at that stage so we should
stay very cautious and wait to hear more
from the police
uh so tell us a little bit about the
location you said it was a residential
location the town of Bravery I believe
is near Kiev it's a historic town uh
what more can you tell us I mean the
helicopter actually crashed into this
preschool kindergarten
yes we're in uh we're in um well it's
effectively a small town on the
outskirts of Kiev the Eastern outskirts
it's about you know 40 minutes drive
from the center of the city and I mean
all around me are apartment blocks
apartment buildings where people are
living and right in the middle you have
this kindergarten it's quite big and
this is where children were at school
children and staff we know that people
have been evacuated we don't know how
many casualties there were in the
nursery but it was up and running it was
open parents had already dropped their
children off at school so you could only
imagine how terrifying and how awful it
has been for many parents this morning
as this news has come through and then
to be here and see half the building
absolutely destroyed and blackened uh
from that crash a very uh worrying scene
indeed and again as I stand Here
residents all around me coming to look
coming to see what has happened in their
area
incredibly shocking distressing for the
residents of the area uh
tell us a bit about can you just recap
some of the facts from this morning we
know that there were 16 people on this
helicopter talk us through uh who else
was on that helicopter
sure well what we know so far is that it
was just after eight o'clock a local
time here in Keith when there was news
that this helicopter had come down at
that point we knew very little about it
we just knew that this helicopter had
come down in this area of bavari east of
Kiev uh and that it had effectively
crashed into a nursery which is
surrounded by residential buildings this
is a residential area lots of families
living here parents had already dropped
their children off at school and what
the police are saying is that at least
16 people have been killed now we can
assume that most of those were on the
helicopter was carrying nine people but
some of course also on the ground police
have said that two children were killed
Emergency Services were here very
quickly they did evacuate other people
residents are being kept back but at
this stage we don't know where the
helicopter is going and where it had
come from and why it crashed it but what
we do know is on board with some senior
political government figures here in
Kiev including Ukraine's interior
minister
okay now bravery I believe is one of the
cities that was originally captured by
Russia and then recaptured by Ukrainian
forces at some point last year tell us a
bit more about what happened when that
took place
yes that's right I mean you might
remember there were images of Tanks
rolling through this part of the city
this town just on the on the edge of the
city but of course eventually those
forces were pushed back it is now a town
on the edge of Kiev like any other where
people are going about their daily
business their daily life as I've said
you know dropping their children off at
school the last thing you'd imagine is
that such a terrible thing would happen
just a few moments later with this
helicopter crash so it's a place that
has experienced uh just under a year ago
that experienced Russian troops coming
through its town and now it is
experiencing a new trauma
okay I just want to go over what we are
reporting here the breaking news 16
people that we know of including
Ukraine's interior Minister as well as
other senior Ministry officials have
been killed this Wednesday at eight
o'clock Ukraine time this morning when a
helicopter crashed outside Kiev in the
town of Bravery this is a town just
outside Kiev we're getting this
information from the national police
chief of Ukraine now the governor of the
key region said earlier on Wednesday
that the helicopter crashed near a
nursery and a residential building early
on Wednesday now two children that we
know of are among the dead 10 of them
are in hospital we're speaking to our
correspondent uh Natasha Butler who is
at the crash site Natasha just described
to us the scene where you are now
yeah well it's it's very quiet so people
are standing around residents and
standing around looking at what is going
on I mean more and more of them arriving
there's a very uh there's a real smell
of smoke and fuel in the air and I'm
just looking behind me here I mean I
don't know if you can see if you can see
the the kindergarten building part of it
is burnt out and blackened there are
Emergency Services picking through that
scene uh and also uh police officers I
mean it's very disturbing picture uh
indeed to see this blackened
kindergarten that is where the
helicopter crashed a few hours ago now
uh it was just after eight o'clock at
local when
residential area you know this is a
Place full of apartment blocks families
people were going to work parents had
already dropped their kids off at school
so very shocking scenes and immediately
after if you look at some of the mobile
phone footage from some of the residents
in these blocks you saw an enormous
spread of fire between these blocks here
in the this park just outside the
nursery what we know now is that at
least 16 people have been killed among
some children two children we understand
a number of children also injured
they've been taken to hospital and on
that helicopter we understand there were
nine people including senior governments
here in including Ukraine Minnesota that
has been killed in this crash you can
only imagine how this news is going to
be received in Kiev in the government
and it's really going to resonate around
Ukraine and people are going to be
asking why on Earth did this helicopter
go down what happened indeed uh just the
the latest lines that I'm seeing uh in
in terms of who was on that helicopter
Ukraine's interior Minister the deputy
interior Minister and a state Secretary
all have been killed in this helicopter
crash east of Kiev we still don't know
where that helicopter was heading why it
crashed 16 people have been killed in
total nine of whom were on board that's
according to the police another 22
people are now in hospital and that
includes two children because the
helicopter crashed near a uh near a
nursery and a residential building
earlier today Wednesday
well
Natasha you you said the Emergency
Services were quick to arrive what would
the procedure there be now when are we
likely to get a little more information
about what happened
are coming you know Moment by moment
when we arrived here we had no idea
about how many people on that helicopter
and within a few
the police are slowly putting out more
and more information about the number of
victims the old or have been injured and
of course the identities of some of
those who are on that helicopter
including Ukraine's interior Minister
such a high profile senior government
figure killed in this crash in this
helicopter that landed on this Nursery
behind me what we can expect is to get
more details as the day goes on would
imagine of course we know that some of
those who are injured have certainly
been
okay it seems we've lost our
correspondent Natasha Butler there who
is right outside the site of that
helicopter crash in the town of Bravery
we will return to her uh in a moment
let's first speak to Peter Zar mayev he
is executive director of the Eurasia
democracy initiative he joins us now
live from Kiev thank you for your time
uh I wondered are you you were obviously
closer to what has happened than I have
any more information about what has
happened uh today regarding this
helicopter crash I don't know well yes
like as you've mentioned in your report
Dennis monasterski who has been a very
active uh minister of internal affairs
and his closest aide uh Mr uh Yuri
lukovich
have all perished in this crash uh
apparently it was very foggy in that
area and before hitting the kindergarten
they may have hit a TV Tower or a radio
tower uh which sent to the helicopter
crashing into the kindergarten killing a
few children right now as many as 18 uh
people are reported to have died uh you
know let me just uh say that all of this
looks very very very suspicious uh you
know usually helicopter uh drivers know
which area they're flying in they are
aware of all the potential obstacles
it's looking very suspicious I would not
rule out Foul Play and by that I mean a
possible terrorist act by the Russian
Federation uh you know like like I said
Minister appointed Journal Affairs is an
important position within the Ukrainian
government who's been taking an active
part in Ukraine's uh resistance to the
uh invading Army so I would not rule out
anything at this point let's let's go
back to the helicopter uh
do you know
social mission where was it going uh do
you have any more information as to why
there were all these senior officials in
this helicopter at the same time
yes apparently they were on a mission uh
that was an internal Affair uh
internal Ministry of Affairs
Affairs Ministry sorry Mission uh we
don't uh know yet exactly what but this
uh this was something very very uh kept
secret at this and so right now they are
staying mom the government is staying
mom excited about what kind of uh
Mission this is but apparently this was
a state business
so you talked about uh the Ukrainian
interior Minister and uh the role that
he's been playing in the War uh between
Russia and Ukraine tell us a bit more
about uh how important how significant
uh what he's been doing has been
well obviously this uh particular
Ministry was responsible for uh rooting
out identifying rooting out world map
potential diversity groups uh which have
infiltrated Ukraine's territories since
the beginning of the war especially in
the Battle of Kiev this was this were
very crucial moments to try to get rid
of internal enemies agents of Russian
influence and saboteurs and so the
Internal Affairs Ministry is crucial in
finding those and this particular
Minister was very active it was very
effective uh and so it seems to me the
Russian Federation would have a direct
motive to neutralize this particular
branch of the Ukrainian government
and and why do you believe that this
could have been a foul play or
deliberate you say that the helicopter
crashed into a TV tower what more can
you tell us about that
well this is a uh you know uh this
rarely happens obviously and it's like
like I said the pilots are very very
experienced it seems that uh there may
have been a device planted within the
helicopter and once again you know
Russia is facing a dire situation the
great it's not having victories and it
seems to me that Vladimir Putin is
growing desperate so anything any trick
uh that he can pull off such as this uh
is I think something that can be uh
expected so at this point it's fake
Motif I don't want to say anything but
you know let's wait a few hours maybe
let's wait till tomorrow until all the
pieces of the puzzles uh start uh you
know coming together
and uh just just tell us a bit more
about this the location of where this uh
this crash occurred and and the
relevance if you think it is relevant uh
bravery of course a key city that was
recaptured by Ukrainian forces from the
Russians last year uh could that have
some kind of relevance do you think
yeah it's a major industrial Hub right
outside the city and it was very crucial
in the battle for bravery was crucial in
uh in this war early on uh and so
um the minister probably was inspecting
some of these uh some of these uh the
industrial uh complexes uh and so once
again you know this little town outside
of Kiev has become you know uh Center of
international news
uh just in case anyone is joining us now
on Al Jazeera uh I just want to cut uh
recap our breaking news 16 people have
been killed in total including two
children uh that is according to the
Ukrainian National Police nine of them
were on board a helicopter and the Crash
occurred next to a kindergarten in
bravery which is east of Kiev we know
now that 22 people are in hospital
including 10 children and what appears
to be quite significant is that the
Ukrainian interior Minister uh
Dennis monasterisk uh probably
pronounced it completely wrong
um was on uh was was in that helicopter
his Deputy was also in that whole
helicopter and they're they're among uh
those killed in that crash on the
outskirts of cave uh
we are talking to uh Our Guest uh
swellastoff yurat many thanks for
speaking to us on Al Jazeera uh if you
can if you can give us your reaction to
this crash I mean what goes through your
mind when when you hear that something
like this has happened
uh well this obviously is a great shot
you know this is uh
um this is just another piece of the
evidence that the Russian Federation
will stop at absolutely nothing to try
to uh you know you know kill the will of
ukrainians uh to resist you know we're
also expecting a major uh announcement
that Vladimir Putin today regarding the
prosecution of the war we're expecting a
new wave of mobilization is gonna make
that quarter uh which once again is to
say that live equipment will not
negotiate he's willing to see this war
until the end of his biological
existence
and tell us a little more about the
interior Minister and the role he was
playing uh in fighting this war against
Russia
Minister Monastery has been extremely
active and effective in routing out and
sniffing out uh targets of Russian uh
covert influence in Ukraine especially
since the beginning of the war when Kiev
was practically infiltrated inundated by
these groups of uh diversionary crack
troops you know
um we call them spies call them
saboteurs uh the point was that they
would would have been used to behead the
Ukrainian government meaning uh
we had as in neutralized and killed the
president early on this was black
recruit his goal and so Minister
monasteries his role was direct very
direct in this uh a particular Affair uh
he was able to neutralize these uh
groups around the country especially in
the capital and basically that cancels
plans to go and decapitate the Ukrainian
government and this has been crucial in
um you know fighting off the enemy from
the capital
okay really good to uh speak to you sir
svet lot of urash uh speaking to us
there uh from Keith
apologies that was uh Peter speaking to
there
let's return to Natasha Butler who joins
us now from bravery near kieve you are
right near the crash site can you
describe to us what you're seeing
Natasha
yeah right outside uh this Nursery that
I don't know if you can make it out
behind me it's a pink building uh half
of it completely blackened by fire now
this is where the helicopter crashed
just after local uh eight o'clock local
time there are a lot of people around me
residents are coming to have a look at
what is happening people are sort of
also looking out of their windows and
apartment buildings
residential area in this town of bavari
which is just on the Eastern outskirts
of the capital uh keys so this was a
nursery where parents had just dropped
their children off at school there was
staff inside at the time when this crash
took place so what we now know just to
bring you up to date is that at least 18
people have been killed that's according
to police including two children we know
also that on that helicopter was senior
government figures including Ukraine's
interior Minister Dennis
monastersky he was on the helicopter
with his Deputy we don't know exactly
where he was going but of course that's
going to send absolute shock waves
through political circles uh here in
Kiev across the country there's such a
senior a figure has been killed this
morning in terms of the actual area I'm
actually just looking now there are more
soldiers arriving and we saw some more
emergency workers as well because they
have been here since early on just after
that crash as you can imagine at the
scene
okay Natasha
um good to speak to you give us a bit
more detail about the rescue operation
you mentioned that there were more
police that you could see we know some
of the casualties are currently in
hospital is that right
yeah that's right we know that a number
of people were injured they were taken
to hospital we know we understand
according to police that some of the
injured our children I mean it's hard to
imagine that there wouldn't be victims
when you look at the state of the
building behind me a kindergarten there
would have been full of children and
staff it's early in the morning they
would have just been dropped off when
this
we know also that there were nine people
on board of that helicopter from what we
understand all of those people have been
killed these senior political figures
including Ukraine's interior Minister
what we don't know though and you know
as I said before is why this helicopter
crashed there had been some residents in
this area who had reported seeing the
helicopter above perhaps with part of it
on fire propeller on fire
foreign
workers are still on the scene the fire
has been put out though because that
spread all around this uh Park a little
bit early huge Blaze if you look at some
of the mobile phone footage that was
taken by some of the residents at the
time and as I've said you know a number
of security officials and emergency
workers more and more starting to arrive
here as well as more residents and
people just coming to see what has
happened right in the middle of their
neighborhood
indeed okay Natasha uh just to recap
what has happened 16 people including
Ukraine's interior Minister we're
hearing there from Natasha and another
senior Ministry official that was we
believe to be the interior Minister's
Deputy had been killed on Wednesday when
a helicopter crashed outside Kiev in the
town of Bravery uh this is a report
we're getting from the National Police
Chief we've heard from the governor of
the Kiev region today that the
helicopter crash near a nursery and a
residential building which has resulted
in the death of two children ten of them
10 children are currently in hospital
foreign
let's return now to Natasha Butler uh
what are the you mentioned Natasha the
shock waves that will be passing through
uh within the Ukrainian government and
the Ukrainian officials who've been
fighting such a tough War uh such a long
war against uh Russia what uh will be
going through their minds right now what
is likely to be their next move
what I've been for the Ukrainian
government it is of course going to be a
huge loss they are losing their interior
minister in the middle of a war as
Ukrainian forces continue uh to battle
Russian forces they have lost the
interior Minister's deputy and these
other senior political figures are on
that helicopter and of course it will be
their their hearts will be going out to
the relatives and families of these
senior figures that have been working so
hard for many months now in Ukraine as
part of Ukraine's war effort and push to
try and push back those Russian forces
for from the country so this will be
huge loss for uh the Ukraine
but
you know questions about why this
helicopter has come down why it came
down here and what exactly happened none
of that we know yet or at least we're
not hearing any reports yet from police
confirming the details of what exactly
happened why this helicopter came down
but those are some of the questions that
you'd imagine are being asked in
government circles and shock and grief
those people they worked with for many
many months in such difficult
circumstances this would be a very sad
day indeed for those in key
indeed
um and and outside Kiev I'm sure um
Natasha Butler there for us just outside
that crash site apologies for the uh
poor sound quality uh let's speak to
Maximilian Hess who is a fellow at the
foreign policy Research Institute he
joins us live on Skype from London good
of you to join us sir your reaction to
this news coming into us in the last
hour so this helicopter carrying the
Ukrainian interior Minister that has uh
that has crashed into this preschool in
the Ukrainian town of Bravery near Kiev
interior Minister one of the people who
has lost his lives along with his Deputy
your reaction to what has happened
thank you for having me uh it's
certainly a tragedy I think that you
know the reaction in Ukraine will focus
on the cause of this helicopter crash
there will of course be investigations
into potential sabotage Ukraine is still
very much actively being attacked by
Russia and that conflict has involved
not only direct kinetic strikes but also
cyber warfare and we have seen targeted
assassination attempts uh both against
Russian occupation officials as well as
against Ukrainian security officials but
that's where suspicion will naturally
fall the interior Ministry in Ukraine is
a particularly important one for the
country's security and also for the rule
of law in the country effectively
overseeing the National Police as well
as many of the domestic Security
Services uh so who comes to replace
monasteries and how the government
handles that will have important
long-term impacts but I don't expect
that it will in any way change the
Ukrainian will to fight or developments
on the battlefield in the very short
term
so tell us a bit more about the role of
the uh the the Ukrainian Minister the
minister of internal affairs I mean how
much of a blow is it to lose him at this
stage in the war
well Monastery had been a trusted Ally
of zelenskies he had replaced that as an
avocov the former long-standing interior
Minister who had dominated that Ministry
from 2014 until 2021 and before the war
was seen as tasked with really cleaning
it up and trying to reform it there have
been many attempts at that in Ukraine's
recent political history not all of
which have been successful in some of
which uh critics within the country have
certainly argued made it worse but the
interior Ministry does oversee some
internal troops and has a security
function as well as overseeing police
functions in the country which are
important to to the ongoing conflict
into Ukraine's ability to ensure that it
is able to best resist Russia but
because a lot of that has been subsumed
by the National Defense committee and
through the military leadership and with
the territorial battalions growing out
of it into those leadership structures
as well I don't think it will affect the
management of the Ukrainian military and
security too directly although of course
if it turns out that this was a sabotage
attack or that otherwise
um Russia and its proxies may have been
behind it that will raise security
concerns for the Ukrainian Ministry
going forward you may recall at the
beginning of this conflict we saw you
know direct attempts in Kiev by Putin's
forces to go after Ukrainian ministers
reportedly president zielinski himself
as well I think it's only natural that
that suspicion will fall there again and
that we made a few changes to their
internal protocol uh security protocols
as well is there any reason uh to
believe that this wasn't a deliberate
action or this wasn't Foul Play I mean
we're hearing now that the helicopter
was of the state emergency service that
the helicopter that crashed could there
have been a more innocent reason uh
malfunction perhaps
um certainly you know I uh helicopters
do uh crafts from time to time including
um some of the weirdest models in the
world
chauffeur High net worth individuals
around uh there have been a number of
prominent incidents like that across the
developing and the developed world uh in
recent years it's certainly not a
foregone conclusion that this was a
sabotage incident or other form of
Russian attack I just think it's natural
that suspicion will fall there given
Putin's ongoing aggression
um but it is possible there is a more
innocent explanation Ukraine's
um Security Services Ukraine's
management of its helicopter foods like
we'll be going into overdrive as a
result of uh Russia's ongoing Invasion
um so there may be a tangential claim
there too as well but no I I I wouldn't
rule out that there's a more interesting
explanation as well but I do think
Ukrainian politics Will Be Fit by
um at least immediately called for
potential investigations and
examinations as to whether this was a
sabotage attack
and uh
I mean you touched on it briefly but
what what likely impact is this going to
have on the situation on the ground in
terms of the fighting itself between
Ukraine and Russia and the focus of the
fighting which is very much the moment
in bakmud will it have any impact at all
I don't expect that we'll have any you
know real Major Impact Ukrainian
soldiers who are fighting button
Ukrainian military leadership have
effective structures to ensure that
they're able to keep operating even in
the event of senior leadership crises uh
or potential Russian sabotage attacks
and cyber attacks as well so they're
they're fairly uh used to fighting under
very difficult circumstances sadly uh by
this point with the sort of full-scale
and Russian invasion ongoing for almost
a year now Putin launched it on the 24th
of February last year uh so I don't
expect there will be a a major change
there one potential area that's
interesting to watch is also how the
pro-russian media and telegram channels
that are cultivated and curated by the
Kremlin uh will respond often they put
out claims of responsibility uh and
things for
acts of aggression that the Kremlin
isn't necessarily directly willing to
state that it carried out for example
the rocket attack that we saw in denipro
last week a lot of telegram channels
um announced that early on back in 2014
when mh-17 was shot down there and so as
well so those will be an area to walk
for potential claims around whether this
was a sabotage attack really good to get
your thoughts maximum Hess fell out the
foreign policy Research Institute uh
speaking to us there from London we're
up to date lots more coming up on the
crash at the top of the hour stay with
us